welcome to another dr sadler's honest
review this is a book review series in
which i look at generally recent
although i'll go back sometimes into the
catalog
recent works that have to do with
practical philosophy in a very broad
sense so it includes philosophy proper
whether it be ancient or contemporary or
anything in between philosophy is a way
of life
ethics those sorts of matters all the
way over into fields like organizational
psychology personal development and
self-help
leadership studies and anything
in between
so the book that i have for us today is
heidi grant's
reinforcements subtitled how to get
people to help you which came out with a
harvard business review press in 2018 so
a fairly recent one
and as usual i'm going to talk about the
3s's style substance structure and
summary
talk about some of the key ideas there's
a bit of overlap there tell you what i
think is good about the book and you
know things that i think are a bit
problematic there are some in this one i
give it a rather
mixed but overall positive review
so and then i'll have a few final
thoughts so that's what we've got in in
this having to do with reinforcements
the style of this book is at the same
time rather easy breezy but also very
carefully crafted if you know how these
kinds of books are
designed and how the editorial and
authorial process works it you can see a
lot of tells in in this book a lot of
short little sections within the
chapters lots and lots of personal
narrative some of which may be you know
entirely on point we don't really know
and there's also lots and lots of very
boiled down references to
classical and contemporary psychological
studies and that's that's a topic that
we're going to get into it's very
readable it's designed to be very
readable i think you can quite easily
tell that
there are a few notes but they're all at
the very end
and there's not an awful lot of them uh
with within this i mean each chapter has
oh about
anywhere from well the top one would be
16
endnotes
most of them don't have quite so much
but it does give you the references it's
got a decent index it's sort of what
you'd expect to come out from harvard
business review
press
and as they say in the book jacket right
it's supposed to be a pragmatic book and
that tells you a little bit about the
summary and the style
it's not supposed to be a scholarly
or academic
or even really very rigorous kind of
book although it does give a lot of i
would say in my view rather helpful
advice uh for the the reader
um
there's lots and lots of anecdotes which
i don't think is a real problem there's
little reminders at the end of every
single chapter
usually three or four bullet points
under a section it helps to remember to
help you you know recall the things that
she's talked about in the last
you know 10 pages or so
and those i think can be decent
summaries of of what's going on within
the chapter um on you know early on in
the book she tells you that the book is
divided into three main parts each of
which aligns with a particular
function a purpose for for writing the
book so she says part one is a deep dive
into why we generally hate
asking for help okay something that's
quite needed
because many of us
don't actually understand why we don't
like asking other people for help when
we
could you know very well deserve it or
need it or
it could be quite useful for us in part
two she says i explain the right ways to
ask for help laying out techniques you
can use to not only increase the odds
people will want to help you
but allow them to feel genuinely good
about doing so and that's an important
distinction it's not just about
success
this is actually i think jumping ahead
one of the good points about the work
there is a kind of
respect for relationships it's not just
a you know how to influence people kind
of kind of book
um the part three she says we'll dive
into why reinforcements
the people need
yeah reinforcements of people need
reinforcements the motivators so she's
using reinforcement in two different
ways you'll see how creating a sense of
us
helps provide an essential form of
reinforcement for high quality
helping and so you know quite quite good
i think
we can basically look at the chapter
titles to get a sense of
what the key ideas are but it also gives
us an idea of the structure and the
summary so i'm just going to run through
them very quickly and then we'll look at
them a little bit more closely when in
the next section so part one has three
chapters uh chapter one it makes us feel
bad help asking people for help
uh
part in chapter two we assume others
will say no and then
chapter three we assume asking for help
makes us less likeable
part two how to ask anyway so there's
three chapters in that one as well the
inherent paradox asking for help
the four steps in getting the help you
need and then actually one of my
favorite chapters don't make it weird
that's a great title right and then part
three uh creating a culture of
helpfulness
the in-group reinforcement
is chapter seven the positive identity
reinforcement chapter eight and uh
chapter nine the effectiveness
reinforcement so you notice she's
invoking this sense of reinforcement in
the the chapter titles by that point
because you've gotten used to thinking
in those those terms and then you know
there's
a few other
bits and pieces
but that's really the the core
of this text
what are some of the key ideas that
you're going to find in this book and
when we talk about key ideas we should
also talk about practices as well these
are actionable ideas so in in chapter
one already which is where the book
begins there's really not a
introduction or forward or anything like
that in any sense um
she talks about there being an inherent
paradox and this is going to get
explored more in a later chapter but the
formulation here is really quite good
while help freely and enthusiastically
given makes the helper feel good
researchers have found that the
emotional benefits of providing help to
others disappear when people feel
controlled when they're instructed to
help when they believe they should help
or when they feel they simply have no
choice but to help in other words a
sense of personal agency that you're
helping because you want to
is essential for reaping the
psychological benefits of giving support
now is this really a paradox or is she
you know chosen perhaps the wrong term
for it i it's that's debatable i don't
i'm not going to worry too much about
that at this point i will say
this
that um this is really a central key
idea for the the book that
you don't want people to feel
just compelled whether it be out of a
sense of duty or you putting pressure on
them or some other thing that's going on
if you want to get them to help and feel
good about helping and you might say
well who cares if they feel good about
helping and there's there's answers to
that that could be provided well if you
want them to be reliable and continue
helping that's important if you care
what other people think then uh
presumably that matters to you as well i
think that applies to most of us then a
little bit later in the same chapter
there's a little clarification about
reinforcements why is the book called
reinforcements because there's two
senses of the word reinforcement
and she goes to google to find out what
these two more specific sub definitions
are
you know did she really
need to go to google i think this is
sort of like being relatable to people
uh but the two ideas are this extra
personnel sent to increase the strength
of an army or similar force the process
of encouraging or establishing a belief
or pattern of behavior especially by
encouragement or reward so we've got
like the personnel side of
reinforcement you know getting people on
your side and then we have the let's
let's strengthen this motive let's
strengthen this behavior let's ensure
that people are going to do this and um
she says that the idea of extra
personnel is is really the basic need i
designed this book to address
when we want people to help us we are
trying to get additional people involved
in whatever it is that we're we're doing
right and then the second notion um she
brings up b.f skinner uh who famously
called the use of reinforcements to make
particular behaviors more likely operant
conditioning
and she says you know people don't
actually work the way exactly the same
way as the rats and pigeons skinner
studied in his laboratory but the
general principle
is spot-on so this tells you where she's
coming from right
um
the book relies a lot on
references to and interpretations of
experimental or organizational
psychology
studies and as i mentioned a little bit
earlier you can get a solid idea about
what she's talking about in each of
these chapters by
looking at the title so in it makes us
feel bad she you know that's essentially
her introduction and then she jumps into
why your brain doesn't like to ask
people for
help and she frames it in terms of all
of these these threats and that's the
end of that chapter chapter two we
assume others will say no why do we
actually make those assumptions you know
what do the the studies have to tell us
about this she goes into you know how
motivation
is structured by
expectation of success and the value of
succeeding um you know she talks about
underestimating helpfulness of people
who said no that's one of the
um
chapters and then she's got some
interesting stuff about cognitive
dissonance here as well
chapter three we assume asking for help
makes us less likable so what is she
doing there she's trying to
examine a very common misconception
really
we often don't have good reason to think
that asking for help is going to make us
less likeable she's got a funny story
here about benjamin franklin and and
borrowing a book
and she says we underestimate how good
giving people uh
how good giving makes people feel when
they get to to give
they
feel better or less bad
and more helping can lead to greater
life satisfaction of course this is you
know relying on a lot of
psychological studies we're going to
talk about that a little bit later and
so that's that's the beginning uh
section and then she starts getting into
the nuts and bolts how do you actually
start getting people to help you and in
chapter four she goes back to this
inherent paradox as she calls it and she
talks about four possible responses
and then
the difference between having to help
and wanting to help which you know could
actually go along
together and how we can sometimes
inadvertently make people feel
compelled to help we can
you know draw on what we think is going
to be helpful for us and getting them to
help but it turns out to be less so
chapter five is very uh nuts and bolts
as well the four steps to getting the
help you need so this is going through
these and each of these steps
is a little bit uh more complicated than
you know just a bullet point list right
uh there's there's
you can talk about those factors um the
things that you need to attend to in
order to get people
feeling okay about about helping you
wanting to actually help and she talks
about obstacles here that you need to
overcome and i think a lot of this is is
pretty
on point
um so that's a really helpful one i
mentioned that i really like chapter six
don't make it weird probably my favorite
part of the book and you know she talks
about a lot of ways in which people do
in fact
make
requesting help from others weird
in different ways and how that's
likely to
um push people away just one example
here that i you know i think a lot of
people can relate to apologizing
profusely you know you don't need to
make it all about you and your apology
if you want somebody else to help you
and i'll just bring in an example here i
often have students who are behind on
their work and they you know talk about
how awful they feel and you know they're
letting me down and all that and i'm i'm
like
listen uh just try to get the work done
on time this is why i have a late policy
they're in effect asking me for clemency
or help and in a certain way
and it does make it weird right um so
this is you know i find this is actually
kind of cool
um
oh here's another another great one uh
emphasizing how much the other person
will love
helping yeah that's that you know
sometimes you don't want to love helping
you just want to help the other person
to to get something done so that this is
a great chapter and she also talks about
like how how to avoid making it weird
or if it if it is weird how to
de-emphasize that
then you know part three is called
creating a culture of helpfulness
and
it's interesting because
you're not really creating a culture
unless you are a person who's at a very
high level
this is harvard business reviews so you
know it's basically aimed at
not just the general public but
would be leadership types and their
emulators
but a lot of this is less creating a
culture and more playing off of
already existing
culture
and i mean it can be about relationships
but i think you know culture and
relationships are kind of bigger so you
know there's like how to create the
sense of being in an in-group that's
what chapter seven is really about
uh and that is a reinforcement the
in-group reinforcement right so you're
and it's the double sense of you're
getting people to like
come in because they feel like you share
an in-group you're also like appealing
to the in-group so that they will then
do what you want them to do
the next one the next reinforcement in
chapter 8 is the positive identity
reinforcement and this has to do less
with
knowing yourself
um and more with getting getting other
people to
understand you but also to
understand their self
in some sort of connection with you i
mean there's a great section here what
helping you
says about me right but this is actually
something that you would turn towards
the other and what helping you
says or what helping me says about you
right and so um
you know this is again trying to get
people to to do what it is that you want
um there's a great point here the
helper's identity matters not yours
that's that's quite true that could
actually fit into the making it weird
and then there's this effectiveness
reinforcement discussion where there's a
lot of stuff being framed in terms of
really big picture stuff bringing in
sigmund freud
talking about the meaning of life
and um talking about impact on on things
seeing your help
land means more
more helping
and how how we can you know in this is a
great thing how you can increase your
helper sense of effectiveness it's not
entirely about increasing their
effectiveness how can you create the
sense the impression that they're
they're being
effective
and then that's that's where the book
ends um there isn't any
sort of like let's wrap it all up here
here's all the different things come
together it's just you know gone through
sequentially so that is that's the key
ideas of this book
all right so what is good about this
this book i think there's quite a few
things that i do like about it there's a
lot of useful advice and
concepts and reminders
that are actionable and i think a person
could take this book
and
read it in light of other things in in
terms of their experience and and and
get some use out of it um i mean a lot
of what's what's being said is said
elsewhere it's not breaking radical new
ground but i think you know we can say
that about many things this could be
quite useful or helpful if you prefer
um you know for somebody who hasn't
thought about these things to
to read or you know somebody who has
thought about them and needs some
reminders about these matters it could
be helpful in that way
there there are some really good
emphases on the connection between
helping as i mentioned before and
agency
and autonomy
i don't i don't think it's really a
paradox as such
but it is something that has to be
thought through and attended to so i
mean it could be a paradox in an
attenuated sense it's not a paradox in
any any real sense this isn't confusing
to to people who understand these
matters but it is really great to
emphasize that if you want people to
not just help but to
have the sort of right motivational
structure for helping and continuing to
help and maybe talking about their
helping
you do need them to buy in and how do
you get them to buy in well there's
there's a lot of stuff about that in
here
um i think there's a lot of good little
sum ups in here
uh about how things work
um i'm gonna just you know talk about
ways to make it weird i mentioned this
is a favorite chapter of mine so what
are the different ways to make it weird
overdoing it on empathy
empathy can be a powerful motivator but
when you're appealing to it too much
that can be a problem
like she says use empathy as a help
seeking tool with caution or it might
achieve the opposite result apologizing
profusely we just talked about that
using disclaimers those seeking help are
so busy trying to establish they're not
personally weak or greedy they turn the
focus away from the helper and on to
themselves
and so that's that's a problem
emphasizing how much the other person
will
love helping
portraying the help you need is a tiny
insignificant factor that's a way of you
know that kind of misleads people right
reminding people that they owe you one
that definitely can make it weird
although you know it depends on what
culture you're in a lot of these things
are
in fact culturally bound
talking about how much their help will
benefit
you
right
that can also turn people off
so you know that's a good listing that's
a good way to work through things
the four steps that i mentioned before
into getting you the help you need
a little bit earlier in the work
in the inherent paradox the four
possible responses to a request for help
i i kind of like seeing this analytics
stuff what are the four possible
responses
no
silence grudging yes enthusiastic yes
there's a little description of each of
these
could there be more yes but these are
most of the gamut of what is going to
happen so i think those are those are
some good things um the the style you
know i mentioned that it's it's really
in some respects kind of artificially
genuine you know artificially
folksy or breezy or something like that
but i think for a lot of readers um you
know it's gonna work they're gonna like
it you can you can read this book fairly
quickly and you're not going to be
caught up by an awful lot of jargon
getting in your way or anything like
that so those are all good points about
the work
i think you could take this and run with
it and it could it could in fact benefit
you
in um
getting people to be more helpful for
you within your life
i did find some things a bit problematic
about the work it's interesting that it
draws so incredibly heavily on
psychological studies and has
almost no engagement with the vast
literature
on giving on reciprocity
on benefits on helpfulness in ancient
philosophy all the way into the modern
times the i mean the one example that
would be uh different from this would be
the discussion of benjamin franklin
um but it's disconnected from
anything else in franklin's work
franklin actually was a a philosopher so
there's a lot of reinventing of the
wheel of things that we might find for
example in seneca's on benefits right or
in in some other works
um
and i think that the reliance on the
psychological studies and theories is
rather fast and loose in a way that
makes me
myself distrust
some of the theorizing that's going on
and some of the blanket statements and
generalizing that's happening in the
work um it's it's almost as if there's
sort of an unnamed fallacy that is sort
of like a fallacious appeal to authority
where you reference a well-known study
that everybody knows proves this
although if you look at the study
carefully it doesn't prove anything
remotely like that right and there's a
lot of ad hoc
stuff and assumptions built into it in
order to get the generalization
that you're looking for
so i you know
i i find that quite problematic myself
the average reader perhaps might go
along with her and be cool with that but
i think that itself is a bit of a
problem i'll just give you one example
of this sort of thing
so she's talking about reciprocity
which is um something that is is you
know been talked about for millennia and
she tells us there are actually three
flavors of reciprocity according to
research by frank flynn and to our
credit you know there's a uh
end note to that what are the three
kinds of reciprocity personal
reciprocity a kind of negotiated
exchange or barter relational
reciprocity the kind of reciprocity we
engage in our actual relationships i
mean that's circular definition right
and then collective reciprocity a kind
of generalized exchange of helping at
the level of a group now does that cover
the gamut of reciprocity in the
literature no um
and you know she's going to use that
and
to be sure
a lot of the practical advice that's
contained in this work that seems like
good advice
could be
stripped away from the
justifications that she's providing it's
almost like that the justifications are
window dressing to provide a sense of
authority to get people to be like oh
well psychologists have said this works
so i'll trust this right it's almost
like a placebo effect in many respects
as a you know as a researcher a
philosopher i find that kind of approach
as i said problematic because it seems
playing pretty fast and loose with with
truth in in a general sense
um but you know maybe you could put that
to the side there there are a few places
where you're like i don't know that this
is actually right
um
towards the end she actually like gets
freud
really wrong you know she says founding
father of psychology and cigar
enthusiast there's like the breezy you
know uh attitude sigmund freud would
give an answer give an answer to what um
what you know what do people need to be
happy what does happiness look like he
would give an answer which formed the
implicit basis for how psychologists
approach motivation for a century big
sweeping statement there too right along
the same lines
he said
human beings wanted to approach pleasure
and avoid pain
period
full stop if something feels good or get
gets us a feel-good reward we do it if
it hurts we don't
now
did freud say that no freud
views about you know
pleasure and pain are way way more
complex than that so what is she doing
you know as a person who's supposed to
know the field of psychology bashing
freud uh using him as a springboard to
launch into her own project basically
lying about what freud actually said to
the reader oh that's you know in my re
in my view that that lowers credibility
and it tells me
this person
is what are they what are they doing i
mean in terms of like helping this is
not helping her case
so you know
did stuff have to be arranged like that
i i don't think so
maybe she actually does believe that in
which case she's wrong about somebody
who's a major
you know early theorist in her her field
or she's saying stuff to try to pander
to the reader either way it's it's it's
a problem so
you know i i don't think that that has
to damn the book as such but these are
things that one should call out
so my final thoughts
it's not a bad book and that's about as
far as i can go it's not a great book
definitely not
it could be a good book depending on how
you use it you should probably if you're
reading this
just ignore her opining and reductionist
stuff about
freud and and probably put aside a lot
of the stuff or take it with a grain of
salt when she says psychology tells us
xyz and just focus on the
actual pragmatic advice that she's
giving you in here and then it can be a
good book for you but it's not a good
book overall
um so i give it a
sort of you know
if if you want to
get ideas about how to get people to
help you in a very practical way i would
check the book out
um i i don't know that i would buy it i
think i would probably get it from a
library rather than purchasing it but
you know people like to buy books and
you know can't hurt
to have it and maybe pass it on to
friends this actually could be a decent
book for
purchasing for somebody
who has a hard time asking other people
for help and maybe it could circulate
maybe this could actually be an article
of help within a giving exchange a type
of reciprocity
right there so a qualified endorsement
of the book on my part
you